le phénomène c'est georges un brave type
lumière devient supérieure dans
intelligent si des mois les noms de
mammifères attention vous avez 60
secondes près allez-y 60 secondes
je vais les classer par ordre
alphabétique un caribou dauphin
éléphants fox-terrier gorille aime ou
pas la jaguar kangourou licorne mammouth
nigaud oslo tendent à renard souris
tigre urus philomène john travolta l'un
des acteurs les mieux payés d'hollywood
depuis pulp fiction
mais après quinze ans de galère combien
de propositions de films recevez-vous
par mois aujourd'hui je ne sais pas m'en
proposait war semaines environ échec et
mat
doucement doucement georges attend
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
qu'est ce qui se passe on entourage
qu'il prenait une chance à fléchir
séparé devoir s'habituer
depuis quelques temps tout pareil clech
j'arrive à discerner les choses disons
que je comprends plus vite chez j'ai
aucun mal à me concentrer les bouquins
je peux pas me rassasier jeu en ligue 2
à 3 par jour et wendake facile ce qui
est intéressant c'est que son
intelligence leurs deux ou trois livres
par jour au moins qui parle de quoi de
tout tout ce qui m'intéresse tout ce que
je voulais apprendre comme quoi des tas
de choses séparent les toits il ya bien
des trucs qui t'intéresse que tu aimeras
prendre
c'est tout sauf un film que vous
détesterez sa dette si vous êtes soir
commence à voir le film a déjà séduit 25
millions d'habitants c'est bien connu